if we jump from human history to the
current particular moment there's
protests in Israel now about the
proposed judicial reform that gives
power to your government to override the
Supreme Court so the critics say that
this gives too much power to you
virtually making you a dictator yeah
well that's ridiculous the mere fact
that you have uh so many demonstrations
and protests some some dictatorship huh
a lot of democracy here more more
ambunctious and more uh robust than just
anywhere on the planet can you still man
the case that this gives this may give
too much power to the the coalition
government to the Prime Minister not
just to you but to those who follow no I
think that's complete hogwash because I
I think there's uh there's a very few
people who are demonstrating against
this quite a few and quite many don't
have an idea what is being discussed
they're basically being sloganized you
can sloganize you know something about
uh not mass media right now but the
social network you can basically feed
deliberately with big data and big money
you can just feed uh slogans and get
into people's minds I'm sure you don't
think I exaggerate because you can tell
me more about that and you can create
Mass mobilization based on these absurd
slogans so here here's where we I come
from and what we're doing what we're
trying to do and what we've changed and
what we're trying to do I'm a 19th
century Democrat in my uh small DDS in
My Views that is I view I asked the
question what is democracy okay so
democracy is uh is the will of the
majority and the protection of the
rights of they call it the rights of the
minority but I say the rights of of the
individual okay so how do you balance
the two okay how do you get the how do
you avoid mabocracy okay and how do you
avoid dictatorship the opposite side the
way you avoid it is something that was
built essentially by British
philosophers and French philosophers but
uh was encapsulated by the founding
fathers of the United States you create
a balance between the three branches of
government okay the legislative
executive and the Judiciary and this
balance is what assures the balance
between majority rights and individual
rights and you have to to balance all of
them okay that balance was maintained in
Israel in its first 50 years and was
gradually over overtaken and basically
broken by the most activist judicial
court on the planet that's what happened
here and gradually over the last uh two
three decades the the court aggregated
for itself the powers of the parliament
and the executive so we're trying to
bring it back into line bring it back
into line into what is common in all
parliamentary democracies and in the
United States doesn't mean taking the
pendulum from one side and bringing it
to the other side we want checks and
balances not uh unrivaled Power just as
we said we want an independent Judiciary
but not an all-powerful Judiciary that
balance does not mean bringing it back
into line doesn't mean that you can have
the uh the Parliament archness that
override any decision that the Supreme
Court does so I pray much early on said
after the judicial reform was introduced
get rid of the idea of a sweeping
override claws that would have with 61
votes that's a majority of one you can
just nullify any Supreme Court decision
so let's move it back into the center so
that's gone and most of the criticism on
the judicial reform was based on a on a
an unlimited override clause which I've
said is simply not going to happen
people are discussing something that
already for six months does not exist
the second point that we received
criticism on was the uh the uh structure
of how do you choose Supreme Court
judges okay how do you support how do
you choose them uh and uh the critics of
uh the reform are saying that the idea
that elected officials should choose
Supreme Court judges is the end of
democracy if that's the case the United
States is not a democracy neither is
France and other are just I don't know
just about every uh every democracy on
on the planet so there is a view here
that uh you can't have the sordid hands
of elected officials uh involved in the
choosing of judges and in the Israeli
system the judicial activism went so far
that effectively the sitting judges have
an effective veto and and
choosing judges which means that this is
a self-selecting court that just
perpetrates itself and we want to
correct that again want to correct it in
a balanced way and that's basically what
we're trying to do so I think there's a
lot of misinformation about that we're
trying to bring Israeli democracy to
where it was in its first 50 years and
it was a stellar democracy it still is
Israel is a democracy it will remain a
democracy uh a vibrant democracy and
believe me the fact that people are
arguing and demonstrating uh in the
streets and protesting is just is the
best proof of that and that's how it
will remain
we spoke about tech companies offline
there's a lot of tech companies nervous
about this judicial reform can you speak
to why a large and small companies have
a future in Israel
because Israel is a free market economy
I had something to do with that I
introduced dozens and dozens of free
market reforms that made Israel move
from seventeen thousand dollars per
capita income
to uh within a very short time to uh
fifty four thousand dollars that's
nominal GDP per capita according to the
IMF and we've overtaken in that uh Japan
France Britain Germany how did that
happen because we unleashed the
the genius that we have in the
initiative and the entrepreneurship that
is latent in our population and to do
that we had to create free markets so we
created that so Israel has one of the
most vibrant free market economies in
the world and the second thing we have
is a permanent investment in conceptual
products because we have a permanent
investment in um uh in the military in
our security services creating uh
basically knowledge workers who then
become knowledge entrepreneurs and so we
create this this structure and that's
not going to go away there's been a
decline in investments in the high-tech
globally I think that's driven by many
factors but the most important one is
the interest rate which which I think
will it'll fluctuate up and down but
Israel will remain a very attractive
country
because it produces so many
so many knowledge workers in a
knowledge-based economy and it's
changing so rapidly the world has
changed you're looking for the places
that have uh Innovation the future
belongs to this to those who innovate
Israel is the uh preeminent Innovation
Nation it has few competitors and I
would say all right where do you have
this close cross-disciplinary uh
fermentation of various skills and areas
I would say it's in Israel and I'll tell
you why we used to be just telecoms
because people went out of the you know
Military Intelligence rnsa but that's
been now broad-based so you find it in
medicine you find it in biology you find
it in agritech you find it everywhere
everything is becoming technologized and
in Israel everybody is dealing in
everything
and that's that's a potent uh reservoir
of talent that the the world is not
going to pass up and in fact is coming
to us we just had Nvidia coming here uh
and uh they decided to build a super
computer in Israel wonder why we've had
Intel coming here and deciding not to
invest 25 billion dollars just now uh in
a new plant in Israel I wonder why I
don't wonder why they know why because
the talent is here and the freedom is
here then it will remain so